here to celebrate some wins with me is
will kane
co-host of fox and friends weekend
feels good to be right doesn't it big
set
want to take a lap or two yeah let's go
we're we're tied into these seats
otherwise so we would and i'd be winning
i'm sure that's the case you're winning
a lot these days um and not just on
being right which to your point we've
all been right yes we've been vindicated
but sadly jesse i don't know if we'll
achieve enough accountability there is
accountability watching
juicy sommelier eat slop in your
estimation for the next 75 days is some
measure of accountability but i want to
know what's going to be added to the
list in the coming months in the coming
years will we get some accountability
from the cdc over the misinformation
they've propagated over the last two
years what about the people that dared
to say something against the masking
cult will they get their social media
feeds back will we find fauci well the
durham investigation will the durham
investigation reveal that the clinton
campaign did in fact
commit crimes against president donald
trump will we get true accountability in
the end on the lies that just do not so
you're saying
the victory lap could last for a very
long time the victory lap should last
as long as and longer than the lies that
continue to be uttered
and i don't see an end to the lies so i
don't see an end to the victory i might
have to stretch before this victory lap
because i already hurt my calf today i
just want to let the audience know i've
been telling you this all day but i hurt
myself today tonight i am playing hurt i
was running in central park little jog
because i have to stay fit for the
victory laps and i'm i'm i'm pacing
myself and i'm just starting off and
this guy whizzes by on a bicycle
and he drops his hat and the hat falls
to the ground and he pedals farther
right and i do the right thing do i run
past the hat will no i stop my jog and i
try to scoop the hat up to deliver it to
this poor hatless man and what happens
as i go down to scoop the hat
i hear something pop in my calf
and now i'm limping and what's your big
takeaway from this moment my big
takeaway is you can't help other people
that's right i would expect nothing less
can we put the lower third back up i
would expect nothing less from a man who
has waters i was right use the pronoun i
on a segment i thought was about we no
we were right
we were right and we remain right and
will kane will remain right tomorrow
morning while he does four hours of fox
and friends weekend we'll see you
tomorrow morning all right man thank you
very much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else